iman chagnaud propose voyage sans
passeport
ben ali où diable se mêle à dieu pour
offrir à l'homme ceux ci
dante en uhf et son univers les légendes
de s'en sont emparés inviolée et quasi
inviolable ce monde reste pure
on le connaître il faut le survoler ce
que nous faisons
pourtant tout ceci a une histoire elle
est simple de jakarta à java 800km nuage
et montagne comme toile de fond
puis les îles de la sonde longue chaîne
volcanique 3500 kilomètres de fûts matra
à timor ben ali et la première île de la
petite sont juste au sud de java qu'elle
touche presque 10 degrés au sud de
l'équateur longue de 150 kilomètres
large de 80 environ les deux tiers de la
corse un million d'habitants religion
hindouiste
le point culminant et à l'umih 4000 m il
est croyez le la tête du cloud qui tient
lille ancré au milieu de l'océan
c'est aussi toujours d'après la légende
le centre du monde autre particularité
il n'y a pas de nord ni de sud il ya le
côté mer il comptait monter
c'est un lieu il faut connaître on y
trouve un temps ce temple celui de
labège atrides c'est le plus grand le
plus vénéré de lille
dans les tropiques les nuages restent
accrochés au sommet des montagnes où il
pleut énormément
plus bas il fait sec et ensoleillé
alors c'est de la montagne que vient
fatalement l'eau de ce fait elle est
source de vie on cultive le riz il ya
trois récoltes par an le rendement à
l'hectare et le plus haut du monde
l'unité sociale abeilles et le village
c'est lui seul qui est propriétaire de
la terre qu'ils prêtent aux villageois
pas d'héritage pas de vente à chacun sa
tâche sur cette terre
un vrai pays pour canards beaucoup d'eau
et des mauvaises herbes
il pousse la parfaite correction jusqu'à
ne pas aimer les jeunes pousses de riz
qu'ils trouvent trop admet-elle on les
conduit en troupeau le matin leurs
propriétaires se munit d'une perche qui
est à son tour muni d'un plu mais et le
soir c'est vrai les canards se
réunissent autour de leur signe de
ralliement et ainsi il est facile de les
ramener à la maison c'est intelligent et
canards les rizières demande pas soin
constant car les parasites pousuites
dans un climat aussi chaud
ce qu'ils n'abordent charmante l'image
du reste
les vaches sont de race battant
la tête là bas sert aussi à transporter
le vie et la paille aussi vous allez le
voir à faire du show
les castes existe ce serait trop beau
les brahmanes castes supérieures de
prêtres ont droit à un parasol noir
la religion est à bali la base de la vie
aussi les manifestations religieuses ne
cesse-t-elle jamais ce sont les femmes
qui apportent les offrandes aux dieux il
on perdrait toute dignité
s'ils ont été vus avec des offrandes mal
fait ce qui n'est pas le cas
pendant ce temps les hommes eux jouent
aux cartes et aux dominos ils ignorent
volontairement tout ce qui se passe
et bien ce qui se passe regardez
m
ces gens qui sur des paysans sont
artistes en tous styles font ils
sculptent de leur temps la pierre
volcanique timbre si près ce n'est pas
fait pour durer mais ça ne fait rien car
bâtir est une occupation normale
les temples sion une enceinte dans
laquelle il y a plusieurs bâtiments à
usage divers hôtels pourront prendre un
bris pour faire la sieste au pied de ces
énormes bagnon on va danser des danses
appelé le long et l'on fera des
pantomimes avec des grands mannequins
appelé john key à fort semblables à ceux
que l'on retrouve en belgique
je me demande qui les a apportées
charmante fillette balinaise déjà fort
plein de mars
elles ont tout de suite neuf ans 8 ans
voilà les jonquet
vous
et
après la fête on cherche à se restaurer
voilà le snack c'est joli
un peu plus loin dans un autre village
on trouve ce sculpteur
vous verrez ce qu'il fait
les formes sont extraordinairement fine
d'ailier il est fort un droit
jolie n'est ce pas
mm
et puis voilà des galettes de riz qui
seront données en offrande pour le
prochain festival autan
à l'occasion de ces fêtes les ballerines
et sortent leurs plus beaux sarron batik
japonais car nice à rome balinais sont
un tissu brodé d'un prix très très élevé
et seulement les gens extrêmement riche
et les danseuses ambre c'est cérémonie
correspondent un peu une sorte de
bénédiction de la nourriture qu'ils
aient déposé là à la vue des dieux mais
cette nourriture sera ensuite ramené à
la maison et servira à nourrir la
famille pendant plusieurs jours
seuls quelques parcelles de toute cette
nourriture sera laissée là et elle sera
dévorée par les chiens
maintenant on rentre chez soi
en remportant la nourriture
e
ce
ivan chagnaud vous a proposé voyage sans
passeport ces démissions a été réalisé
avec le concours de françois motta et de
solange péters montage michel la touche
script du set enlevé y sont jean-paul
tic emploi illustrations sonores
jean michel pont ramier